herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
welt oder in unserer trotten weltspitze
gleich sauer gelb heute gibt es
eigentlich noch gar nicht richtig sagen
aber heute gibt es ein herbstliches
rezept und zwar das mikrofon musste
verlassen und zwar beginnt jetzt für uns
die kürbis saison und ich habe deswegen
ein rezept mit kürbis ausgesuchte
zwischen amerikanisches und ich möchte
hört eine kürbis torte machen
der kürbis wird findet in der zeit
eingearbeitet das heißt der teig wird
auch richtig schön feucht und nicht so
trocken er wird aber auch nicht so
locker als ziemlich viel lufteinschlüsse
drin sondern es ist eher ein weißer
tiger vorstadt treibt unten sehr fein
partei
ich würde sagen ich starte jetzt einfach
mal wieder zarte sie sehr einfach zu
machen und geht auch relativ schnell und
ich sage ich jetzt hier für einmal die
zutaten für den teig brachen wir 170
gramm weiße butter 125 gramm weißen
zucker
125 km braunen zucker ihr könnt auch nur
weißen zucker nehmen daneben 250 gramm
aber der brauner zucker gibt noch mal
einen schönen geschmack mit dazu drei
eier in größe l 100 gramm butter mädels
ihr könnt auch normale milch verwenden
aber ich möchte damit nehme eine gute
prise salz einen halben teelöffel zimt
180 gramm mehl 75 kakaopulver eine
packung backpulver
und hier habe ich eine hokkaido kürbis
und hier vornehmlich mir 200 gramm
ich nehme ganz gerne riesenkürbis weil
man diese nicht stehlen muss und man die
schale mit verwenden kann
zuerst nehme ich mir jetzt die 200 gramm
von meinem kürbis weg und wie gesagt
dass ich bei meinem kürbis die schale
dran
die kerne müssen aber natürlich mit
einem löffel entfernt werden den kürbis
schneide ich dann in kleine würfel damit
ich sie gleich jahren kann die
kürbiswürfel kommen dann in einen großen
topf und werden dann mit etwas wasser
überdeckt ihr könnt auch gerne etwas
mehr wasser nehmen und dann werden sie
bei mittlerer hitze auf dem herd gegart
bis sie weich sind
in der zwischenzeit nehme ich mir schon
meine zweite klinge und zwar backe ich
in zwei back ringen damit der teig
einfach gleichmäßiger wert diese haben
jeweils 20 cm durchmesser und ich
verschließe jetzt hier mit backpapier
damit kein teig ausrollen
ihr könnt auch gerne ein paar hardware
man benutzen um sie festzustecken
mein kürbis ist inzwischen weichgekocht
saß ich nur noch den wasserdampf
entweichen und das ganze wasser
verdunsten mit einem pürierstab pürieren
ich dann den kürbis richtig schön durch
so dass keine stücke enthalten
anschließend nämlich dem pürierstab vom
strom weg und entferne das messer und
dann erst dürft ihr das messer eben
abschaben also können teilnehmen und die
kompletten reiste des kürbisses
entfernen
das kürbispüree dass ich jetzt kurz
abkühlen und geht in dieser zeit die
butter in einem topf und geht mit den
weißen und den braunen zucker zu und lag
es richtig schön cremig rühren
danach gebe ich meine eier einzeln mit
dazu und lass es weiter
anschließend kommen jetzt alle zutaten
rein also
backpulver
sind
gotha - und natürlich auch das glück
dieses ist jetzt mittlerweile schon
etwas abgekühlt und jetzt wird alles
ganz ganz eingerührt am besten mit
spritzschutz nur so lange rühren bis
sich der teil komplett verbunden hat es
kann sein dass ihr vielleicht noch ein
bisschen butter milch braucht es soll
einfach ein schöner geschmeidiger
teigwaren der nicht zu fest aber auch
nicht flüssig ist und dann fühlen wir
dann zeigten die beiden vorbereiteten
die teiglinge
und dieser mann hat recht der teig
gespräche sein
bis 3
und so werden die beiden kuchenteig
jetzt bei 175 grad ober und unterhitze
für etwa 35 bis 40 minuten gebacken
ich werde auf jeden fall nach etwa 30
minuten bereits mit stäbchen probe
machen denn jeder ofen bug der andere
meint hat insgesamt hat 30 minuten
gebraucht und jetzt lege ich ihnen auf
ein abstürzt gitter und las ihnen da
komplett auskühlen
das macht ihr am besten mit einem
geschirrtuch damit der teig nicht
austrocknet für die creme brauchen wir
200 g schlagsahne dies kalt 200k
mascarpone da könnt ihr auch frischkäse
nehmen aber ich bevorzuge mascarpone 100
gramm put in zukunft das schale einer
bio orange die habe ich jetzt auch schon
heiß abgewaschen den halben teelöffel
zimt etwas vanilleschote oder da könnt
ihr auch einfach eine packung
vanillezucker nehmen
ein teelöffel sun abfahrt das kennt ihr
bereits das habe ich schon öfter gezeigt
und zwar ist es diese sahnesteif mittel
ohne gelatine und das ist eben auch für
veganer sehr gut geeignet und das sind
auch keine künstlichen zusätze drin
sondern dass es nur stärke und ein
bisschen zucker genau diesen orange und
wenn ihr möchtet dass eure creme orange
mit könnt ihr einfach passend farben
dafür genommen
ich nehme jetzt einfach diese passten
von deco packte er mich vor kurzem auch
mit von dort ausprobiert und die sind
echt super gut gefällt mir das massiv
vorne losgehen kann
hier das ist ja so nett aber man muss
sich nicht mit zahnstocher reihen
sondern jetzt auch noch seine basieren
also geschäfts ganz frisch weil die
anderen lehrer und die sind nicht so
ganz passt es wie meine anderen farben
aber sie sind eben mehr so gillard ich
und das finde ich jetzt bei der creme
super weil es sich dann besser auflöst
aber auch für fondant und für andere
sachen richtig gut geeignet meine schlag
sahne verrührt jetzt ganz kurz und gäbe
dann gleich das sommerbad pulver mit
dazu und es so lange bis es schreit ist
die steif geschlagene sahne gebe ich
dann in den kühlschrank und gäbe in
dieser zeit meiner mascarpone in meinen
hört auf da kommt das zimtpulver mit
dazu
der puderzucker die abgeriebene schale
der orange und das versuche ich jetzt
ganz kurz das macht ihr aber bitte
zuerst mit einem teig sarah ansonsten
kann es passieren dass die ganze küche
50 wird und dann verrät es nur ganz kurz
mascarpone hat einen sehr hohen
fettgehalt und wenn ihr diese zu lange
wird gerät euch die everster können dann
gebe ich tröpfchenweise die farbe mit
dazu und hier dürfte ruhig etwas mehr
farbe benutzen
denn wenn jetzt die sahne mit dazu kommt
wird es dann sehr wieder heller die
sahne wird dann nur kurz unter gehoben
und dann stelle ich meine krähenbühl
meinen trockenboden habe ich jetzt schon
auf eine tortenplatte gegeben
und hier hilft mir samira dabei ein paar
backpapier streifen darunter zu legen
damit die tortenplatte nicht schmutzig
werden
nun gebe ich etwa ein drittel meiner
creme auf den ersten boden und verteilt
ihn mit meiner winkel palette dann kommt
der zweite boden oben drauf und ich
bedenke die torte mit der kompletten
restlichen creme zuerst auf der
oberseite und dann an den rändern
und da arbeite ich immer ganz gerne mit
dinkel paletten und strahlt paletten
dann könnt ihr die papierstreifen
entfernen und die torte für eine stunde
kühlen und für die gastro verwende ich
100 bitterschokolade 1 esslöffel berlin
und ich bin uns auch gleich etwas sahne
die habe ich jetzt vergessen zu stellen
ich gebe zwei drittel der show privater
gemeinsam mit dem kamin in einer
schüssel und schmelzen über dem
wasserbad und gäbe dann erst das
restliche drittel dazu und höre so lange
bis sich die schokolade komplett
aufgelöst hatte anschließend könnt ihr
noch einen schlag sahne dazugeben und
werde dann feststellen dass die krähen
jetzt etwas dicker wird
dass es jetzt eine garage und die soll
ebenso dick sein dass sie zwar noch
fliesen kann aber nicht so flüssig sein
dass sie eben komplett an der torte
herunter fließt und diese gebe ich auf
meine gut gefüllte torte
um diesen schönen tropfen effekt zu
erzählen könnt ihr einfach mit einem
kleinen löffel die tröpfchen etwas
runter ziehen und die schokolade am rand
herunter laufen lassen
die torte muss dann nicht mehr gekühlt
werden sie ist sofort verzehrfertig und
sieht ihm an schnitt dann so aus im
kühlschrank ist die torte dann etwa zwei
bis drei tage haltbar
aber natürlich schmeckt sie frisch am
allerbesten die torte ist samtig und
sehr weich und im geschmack richtig
schön schokoladig und etwas auf rasche
und das fand ich natürlich sein
für mich persönlich war die torte in
ganz kleinen themen zu süß meine eltern
und mein mann
die fanden es super ich würde an manchen
stellen den zucker reduzieren weil ich
eher nicht so süß mag deswegen schreibe
ich euch dieses rezept wie ich es
gemacht habe auf meinem blog schreibe
ich aber in klammer einfach dazu wie
viel zucker ich jetzt persönlich
reduzieren würde
es war nicht extrem viel aber ich bin
erst oder typ der nicht gerne zu süß mag
die hat die kirche ist heute auch
geschwächt gelb endlich ein ja und ich
werde jetzt parallel zu diesem video
noch ein anderes video hochladen und
zwar habe ich gefilmt wie ich meine
küche geplant habe wie meine küche
aussieht und natürlich was gut und was
schlecht ist
und erzähle ich euch einfach auf was in
zukunft also in nächster zeit für andere
videos folgen dieser mehr alles gleich
wieder was anderes backen deswegen gehen
wir noch mal an kühlschrank holen unsere
paar zutaten euch wünschen wir ganz viel
spaß mit dem rezept probiert auf jeden
fall mal aus und schickt uns die bilder
auf facebook und instagram und bald
mache ich mir auch einen twitter account
das hatte ich bisher noch nicht aber das
kommt jetzt auch